We are here today to talk with
Tony and chain of voltaic systems.
Um, and I'm going to give you first a
little bit of background. So first is, um,
at maker faire last year, um, I
had my solar powered bike home,
which, you know, does not power my ride to
work, although that's version three. Um,
when it does is it avoids the
problem that was happening.
Whereas I kept getting almost
hit on coming up to bridge
the Williamsburg Bridge
because I never put the batteries
in my lights because you know,
batteries wear out and then I'm just
too busy and distract the decks.
You replaced them. Some wife
said, come on, genius, you should,
we'll lose somebody about this.
So I found this lovely solar,
I went through with several panels,
found this lovely solar panel and put
some yellow tape and a headlight on and
now I didn't have that excuse anymore.
And the mantra achieve, um, efficiencies.
What were my morning commute in,
in the sun,
powered my evening commute home
in the dark and all of as well.
So I was at a maker faire showing this
off and Tony walked up to him just like
very innocently and quite quite
dust slyly as really, hey,
what panel is that? I said, you know,
I went through like I think
four different panels,
did some very crude but effective
testing and this was the best one for
efficiency per square
centimeter of servicing. It's
like, that's great to hear.
Where did you get, I said eight 40
goals. That's really great to hear.
I'm Tony from voltaic systems.
That's my panel. And um,
we went back and forth a little
bit with the actual finished,
he wants to say best one I've found and
I did try like at least four. I remember,
um, he even gave me a free panel
for being such a loyal, loyal fan.
And I'm a big fan of this.
If you have never heard this quote,
really Tesla said it best. The Sun
is the spring that drives all right.
Electricity coming down and a wall came
maybe from a hydroelectric plant that
was powered by water falling down,
water got up through evaporation,
evaporation and eclipse of the sun.
And Wind.
The wind is because the sun heats up the
air. It's all from the sun. Of course,
every transformation loses a bit.
So the closer,
the more direct to connection
you can make to better,
which in my opinion would photo the
photovoltaics are all about right.
Take the energy, put it right into
the device, right into electricity,
and do it as close to
the need as possible,
which is pretty much what their
company does. With no further ado,
I'm going to turn it over to Tony
and Shane. Guys, it's all yours.
All right, well, um, I
just a little background,
turn this on.
So voltaic I started about
10 years ago and really, uh,
maybe a caveat for census rooms full
of engineers. Uh, I'm not an engineer.
I'm a business guy and I'd been
doing dotcom startups and so on.
I'm just interested in environmental
issues and um, started looking at,
at solar technology,
sort of inspired by the flexible solar
panels were coming out and the idea that
those new technologies would open up
new possibilities, new applications.
Uh,
I was slacking off in Spain at the time
and I had little solar charger with me
and I carry it around everywhere
inside my bag. And, um,
with the intention of
charging my cell phone.
But what I found was that my bag was
in the sun all the time and I'd been,
I'd never actually pulled this thing out
and set it up and pointed at the sun.
And so after awhile it became obvious,
okay,
somebody should put a panel on the outside
of a bag and then you don't have that
hassle and it's going to
be generating power all the
time. So, you know, that was,
that's where we came from.
That's a,
this is the latest iteration
of that original idea,
a solar panel on the outside battery
inside generating a charge and then a Usb
port to plug in whatever
you need to charge. Uh,
from there we really expanded,
you know,
it was sort of a design project.
I didn't really see myself as all that
qualified to be doing it, but we're,
nobody did. After a couple of years
I thought, what the hell? And, um,
we got a tremendous amount of press and
a lot of customers and we were there and
in business.
And so the challenge became the design,
a full line of bags and recharge tablets
and laptops and all that sort of thing.
Uh, ultimately the way
it's gone, consortium, Sia,
a product line there. Um, we're doing, uh,
most recently a bunch of solar lights,
uh,
which are specifically for emergency
preparedness and developing countries,
probably most relevant to the
makers, uh, uh, panels like this one.
It turned out that we way over
engineered the panels and,
but when people discovered
that they became useful for
all sorts of applications,
and so now we're selling through eight
are fruit and spark fun. And, uh,
some of those makers are coming back
to us in the end and saying, okay,
now I need a custom panel. And so now
we're in the custom panel business, Tony,
or sit down and design a custom panel to,
to whatever specs the engineers
are looking for. And uh, so that's,
that's kind of Valtech in a nutshell.
So
has it been moving more further away
or more towards the end consumer,
but how much of the DIY maker
demand is the business occupied with
the,
uh,
I dunno,
I'd say probably still less than 20%,
but certainly growing quite significantly.
It's probably the fastest growing
segment of our market. Uh,
that and the custom panel business
custom tweaks that people want.
Sure. So, um, the,
the two biggest things that they want
tweaked would be a power specifically for
their project or the size.
Maybe they have a box that
they've designed for their
sensor or their project,
whatever happens to be and they want some,
uh,
panel to beautifully fit
the box instead of looking
like an off the shelf panel was slapped
on top later. But how it's shape,
like if I wanted to do Deca, he'd driven,
could they come to, you could, we can,
we can do all different
types of shapes and forms.
So it's certainly possible. Yeah. People
have asked about circular solar panels,
triangular solar panels,
and that's all possible.
Usually they come back to rectangles.
It's more economical and for the power
to square centimeter if you just use a
rectangle. But all different types
of shapes there's or in the hospital,
the flexible panels work
defined work.
The short answer is yes.
Are they,
do they approach like the rigid is any
reason that they're not as efficient as
the fixed panels?
Actually, I lifted this chart
from the web that shows,
it's, it's a crazy chart. My, uh,
former consulting buddies would frown
at me for putting this up, but uh,
this basically shows all of the
different solar technologies from the,
from the mid seventies
to now. And um, you know,
the flexible ones are pretty much those
green lines at the thin film panels.
And so they're actually starting to
approach the efficiency of the silicon
cells,
which are the blue lines.
Oh, it's actually a
different material in them.
Typically. I mean, uh,
amorphous silicon is actually silicon
just in a different format, but the,
uh, Kevin and Telluride and sig cells
are the other sort of leading, um,
thin film panels and those,
those are just using different
chemical structures to,
to produce the same result.
But the thing that really matters is the
cost and silicon has come way down in
cost for interim silicon panels.
And so dominates the market.
It's 90% of the installed base,
a traditional monocrystalline of
polycrystalline silicon cells.
What kind of efficiency gains do you get?
If you can start like,
like I have a very simple crude solar
tracker and it looks to me like double
digit percentages better.
Is that like really,
is that a big gain or
their gains you made?
And like maybe changing the shapes
that a thesis has more facets.
Where do you get the biggest
bang for the buck and you know,
facing the sun so to speak?
Um, so solar track is definitely
making huge difference. Um,
and I'll tell you what,
if you take a panel and face it directly
towards the sun and then even just lay
it flat, you know, 30 degrees
off that direct angle,
you're probably losing 30,
40% of your power.
And so you think about the sun
moving through the sky, you know,
and your panel is facing this way and the
sun's over there and over there during
the day you might be at 30,
you know, early in the day, 30,
40% of the potential power of that panel.
If you can track it all day long,
then absolutely double digit
gains in the output of the panel.
Um, do the, I guess it's
probably varies with the,
with the different chemistry
in the different, in the
different types of panels,
but do panels like how far in the,
in the spectrum to their, does their,
let's Say v Vision Extend, does infrared
work, does ultraviolet contribute?
Is there like a reason to not filter,
for example,
with the pane of glass
for pain of acrylic,
the curve on the graph on the
right answers your question.
That's the spectral response
of how monocrystalline
solar panels respond to a UV
light.
And I each solar cell,
it responds to different
wavelengths of light better. So, uh,
the ones that we use monocrystalline
cells are more geared towards a 1000
nanometer, um, the wavelength of light.
But there could be other types of cells
like these multi junction cells which go
on satellites,
which respond to all different wavelengths
of light and that can absorb a lot
more power.
And this is one of the reasons that
the efficiency of solar panels is,
is limited because they can only really
turn certain wavelengths of light into
electricity, but, but not all of it.
Are there any, I mean this probably, I'm
sure that if I thought about this first,
I wouldn't ask this question, but
are there any like compounds, cells,
where would you like just interleave
you know, the different types.
So here in this large services,
we have 40% of each portion
of the spectrum represented.
Yeah, that's a great question.
Uh, it is, the answer is yes,
they're called multi junction cells
and that that's what goes for if you're
incredibly space constrained
and finances are not a question,
uh, so it'd be sort of your,
the government then, uh,
they'll put those on satellites and
Mars rovers and stuff like that.
And that's where they can get,
um,
30 to 40% efficiency on,
on the panel, which had,
but there'll be paying,
you know,
a hundred times more than
what the consumers are a,
but if you're a rover on Mars,
so you can afford that.
Whereas the efficiency
of consumer product,
solar panels and rooftop
modules would be 18 to 24%.
Okay. Yeah. And that kind of
thing, like, yeah. When space
is what counts, not money,
I'm shipping it tomorrows.
Exactly. You know, I've got money.
I don't have rocket fuel.
Exactly. Exactly. Um, what are,
what are the popular consumer product
for the, like for the bags and backpacks?
What are people buying them?
The bags have certainly been popular,
probably the sort of mainstream product.
Uh, actually we have one here, this,
uh, this, uh, fold up solar panels.
So that's kind of the most common thing
you would see on Amazon or somewhere
that,
that is basically just a straight panel,
a USB port on it with a regulator,
a skipping the battery entirely.
And so as a consequence, a lot
cheaper, pretty easy to make. Um,
and these are, you know, these
are really everywhere. Uh,
the challenge is that as soon as you're
charging a device straight from the
solar panel,
the regulation of it gets difficult.
And particularly with specific
brands of phones and so on,
they've got all sorts
of protections in the,
in the circuitry that essentially
mean you heard that well.
Yes. Uh, and so, you know,
you put it out in the sun,
but there's a cloud and then all of a
sudden the power drops and the phone won't
let it recover. And so, you know,
real advantages with these that they're
lightweight and they're relatively cheap,
but, uh, some, some challenges in
getting them to charge all devices
thing. To me, he says just one
intro battery and plan ahead.
Well, exactly. Yeah. And that's
what we do. And you know,
all of that bags have a battery in.
And you know,
really that's the more convenient approach
anyway. Because if you're, I mean,
if you happen to need a charge when
you're in the sun, Great. But if that,
those two things don't coincide,
then really you need a battery to
bridge that gap. And so a better,
a better approach is to have
a battery in the mix somewhere
to campus typically buy these parts or
is it like people who live in the city
who just want to have one that I use the
cameras need it or want it has a very
distinctive line between them?
Yeah, I think so. I'm
sure there's a, you know,
I mean we see where our
products are shipping and,
and certainly there are plenty going
to New York City and other places. Um,
and probably people could get
away without it and in many cases,
but then some of the applications,
there's really no other option. You know,
we've got photographers a spending weeks
out in jungles or remote places and
they need to run the cameras.
There's not really another option or
you're remote environmental sensors that
are going to be sitting there on
their own for a year. You know, they,
they need these panels and uh, a lot
of adventure travelers and pretty cool.
It's like,
you know,
60 year old lady hiking through the desert
with a camel for pretty much the last
20 years. Yeah. I wish I had the
picture, actually. She's fantastic.
Um,
so lots of,
lots of diverse applications and
certainly those worst solar's the only
realistic option.
You can't like a battery and with you
if it's an extended period of time,
wind isn't viable.
And,
and solar is the only thing that you can
trim it down to the size you need and
carry with you.
So
yeah. So something you talked
about earlier with me at lunch,
I want to bring up now where,
what's happening in like,
I think it was Subsaharan Africa,
what's, what are you doing?
They're not personally,
but you know, as a company.
Sure. Um, not, not as much as
I would like. Uh, you know,
it's really,
uh,
there's a tremendous opportunity to
have a huge impact in those places,
the other places without,
with lots of Sun and not a lot
of existing infrastructure.
Exactly, exactly. So, you know,
1.2 be and people apparently without
electricity in the world and most of those
people are in sub Saharan Africa,
uh,
and then another billion with
totally unreliable electricity.
And when you think about it,
the grid in many cases just hasn't made
it to those people and is probably never
going to.
And what we'll have is something like
the same sort leap frog we have with cell
phones bypassing the wired
telephone network is,
is happening now with solar
and you can avoid, you know,
you can give up on ever getting the
grid so long as you can have a viable
alternative where solar energy,
um, and, and it, it is happening.
It's been obvious that that should happen.
The problem is much of the
market has been poisoned by junk.
They're really cheap,
shoddy products that poor people are
spending a big chunk of their income on
only to find out at the
end of the day that it's,
it's not working as they expected it to.
It doesn't last as well.
So I guess what we're
doing, um, first of all,
we've designed solar lights that are high
quality and good work properly and, uh,
and we're trying to get
those into those markets.
The biggest challenge is getting
our costs down so that it's viable.
And then we work with a lot of
aid organizations, uh, that,
that are doing a I the survey
work or post disaster recovery,
that sort of thing in, in
those markets. So there,
there's some of our bigger customers
are at the top of the list there. Uh,
so yeah,
there they're probably right.
The two main things we're doing that
if today I want to say like,
what's the,
what's the most popular use case in
New York City? What are your products?
What do you think it is
in New York City? I don't know. Perhaps
the bike helmet is going to take off.
Not out to them.
There's my Kickstarter.
Um, you know, honestly the, the
challenge in New York City is,
is even getting any sunlight.
And you know, so we've done, uh,
a number of installations where it'll be,
for example,
an emergency lighting situation.
I did a micro apartment where we put a
little panels on the ledge and we ran and
threw it or battery and a lighting system.
So that in the event of a blackout,
you've still got a way to charge your
phone and light. Um, but it's, it's not,
it's sort of mainstream application that
was really sort of a, an experiment.
There are a bunch of data
centers around the place. Um,
Tony actually built one,
which, uh, top left,
there was a air quality monitor.
Uh,
and there's similarly, you know,
water level monitors in the,
in the rivers that are
going to detect either a,
the level of the water or the quality
of the water, those sort of things.
And I think probably iot
applications of that nature,
environmental sensors are
going to be one of the,
the sort of main opportunities you
see them on. Not our product, sadly,
but,
uh,
all the city bike stations
have a solar panel on them.
I remember seeing light,
I think like maybe emergency phones on
what are the bridges that writing across
a big solar panel on top.
True. Yeah. And parking meters
as well for that matter. Uh,
certainly anywhere where you
don't want to have to uh,
run AC power,
then solar starts
to make sense.
The challenge is as,
as you see with this example
of the city by panel, it's,
it's beautiful looking panel,
but it's in a canyon.
And so the period of time during
which it'll get direct sun,
which is a 30 degree.
Exactly. It's very limited. And
then, um, you know, to make it worse,
the panel's not oriented towards the Sun.
Uh, and so it will get even less power.
Yeah. Yeah. And then, you know,
probably for reasons of design,
it's actually that poll that it's
inside uses a tinted plastic,
uh, which really mess this
up a little more clearly.
It wasn't a solar engineer designing
that, but you know, it is beautiful.
So actually I'm going to take some of
the products brought and passed them
around. That's a good one to pass around.
That's a, that's our new solar light.
That's a mighty break load.
Leds are so efficient nowadays
that the opportunity for,
so lighting's really
opened up. Uh, and so,
you know, in the next few years
we will see that penetration of,
of finally solar lighting into these
places that he currently using kerosene.
So where do you see where he
said the next big, what's it,
what's the big opportunity waiting
for volt, painful for, you know,
portable solar products in general
for you specifically? Like what's,
what's the next thing to
do that has an impact?
The next big opportunity for us ties
into the next big trend in the tech world
of connected devices and smart devices.
And there's estimates that say there's
going to be billions of connected smart
devices in the world within the next
few years and less than 10 years.
And so much of those need to be powered
off the grid, uh, visit a smart microwave.
Of course it can be powered, but if it
was some other connected device for,
for cities are scientists
that's out in the wilderness,
it's going to need some sort of
power in the most reliable sources,
typically solar power.
So I think we,
we've already got a start with that
with some momentum with the custom solar
panels that we're doing for, for sensors
and, and scientists and other projects.
Um, but I'm really excited to see where
that goes and see how we can use those
sensors on a macro scale. That was
such a perfect answer. So I have,
so I'll share with my current project is
I'm going to buy a bunch of panels for
is I'm in charge of my
parents former home.
I've turned off the electricity there,
but I still want a burglar alarm. Sure.
That's all particle up there. So I've got
a particle electron. I'm looking at you.
How well I can tell the parent basically
send me an SMS if you see any emotion
because she couldn't be an emotion here.
Sure. That's exactly what I was thinking.
Yeah. I'll help you find
the perfect panel for that.
Talk to me offline and you know what, I
think, um, it's a good time for Q and a.
Any questions relative to the Allen?
Let me just repeat it. Okay. Repeat. Okay.
Why do you think solar has penetrate data?
Even things like example,
like park rooftops, uh,
like things that, that we use everyday
and then suddenly you're like,
I need to return something and I don't
have anything that I can like take out of
it.
Like a car has a battery,
but you can not take a rechargeable
device out of the car that has been
recharging justify the solar panel.
He's like, it's something that,
that piece out their own
design when the design.
So the question is why having the solar
panels penetrated or made their way into
more ubiquitous places? For
example, the roof of a car,
when a car has a battery
to hold the charge,
why isn't it this whole panel attached?
Why isn't it part of the things
that are out there already? Right.
Why are they separate?
Is that an effect?
It,
I wanted the same thing because it does
seem like a logical place to be putting
solar panels in, particularly
with electric cars coming
online. You'd be thinking,
okay, well that should be just
covered in solar panels. Um,
I think the problem,
particularly running an electric car is
that the power demand versus the amount
of power you're going to generate from
those panels is, is a long way apart. The,
you know,
the area of a car is just nowhere
near big enough to actually run a car.
Um, but you could see that, you know,
you might have a soul, a sunroof,
and I've, I've seen solar sun rooms
and bonnets and that sort of thing,
and they'll be used to sort of trickle
charge the battery and potentially run,
you know, a fan to keep it cool when
it's parked, that sort of thing.
But it's pretty limited applications.
And when you think about it,
the cost of integrating that panel into
the roof of the car is relatively high
and it's then competing with the
alternator in the car as a power source.
And it's a lot easier just to use the
gasoline in the car to run that and
produce energy and recharge
the battery that way.
And so I suspect that's the
calculation that that goes on.
And so really it's when the engine's off,
you've got a chance to competing and
that sort of the smaller scale trickle
charger to keep the battery running and
maybe a small fan or whatever else you
need running when it's turned off
customer and his bag is probably
five years old or something.
One thing I'm wondering about and you
must be getting bored if love advertising
because I must've had like over a
hundred people over the last five year as
I'm wondering how much you got
it has helped your business.
Because when I look at what you do,
maybe this isn't actually,
it's already markets, right?
This is, this is nice.
This is probably not the snare a year ago.
So I'm kind of curious how that works.
So the question is with a lot of all word
of mouth advertising generated by one
of our already in February,
um, you must have,
you must have consumer demand coming in,
but like it seems like maybe
that's not your end goal.
No, I think it is our end goal
when in fact, I think your, uh,
your represented dominant chunk of
our marketing strategy. We, you know,
we're a small company with limited budget.
It's a niche product. And so, you know,
it doesn't work out for us to spend a
lot of money on advertising and that sort
of thing, but you're
affectively, you know,
walking around with a billboard
a that says voltaic and,
and I get the same thing.
People constantly are asking
about it and it's great.
You know,
it's one of the things we achieve,
I think is to initiate a conversation
about solar and, you know,
does it work and how do you make it work?
That sort of thing.
And I wouldn't say that it's necessarily
irrelevant in a city environment.
You can still get periods where
you're getting enough sunshine to, uh,
to maintain a phone or whatever.
And also there's a battery inside,
so even if you're not,
it's the middle of winter and you're
in New York can still plug it in.
It's really a universal charger. But, um,
I don't know. You may have noticed we,
when we ship the bag out,
there's a bunch of little business cards
in there with our URL on it and yeah,
exactly. They're gone. And, uh, and you
know, often people write into us and say,
can I have some more cards? Because
really sick of writing down the URL,
I want to give them out,
which is fantastic to hear that.
Yeah. I mean, I know every, every,
every traffic stop at least once a ride,
someone asks about the
helmet. Seriously. And yeah,
most people say what's that said like
dish, but it's on them to get it right.
It's a very distinctive and the AC
hum. Let's me in keeping me awake.
What a question. This might be
more of a battery of questions,
but one of my side projects
and all is up off the grid,
small server.
But the problem that I run into is
finding a small battery pack that can be
charged
on the solutions that I buy online
are use [inaudible] acid battery
recommendations.
Uh, so, so recommendations
or the, um, the question is,
um, he's looking for personal
project. I'm basically,
he wants to, he wants to charge and
draw at the same time for battery.
Perfect.
Right. And, and it's surprising,
but that's a common problem.
If you look at typical battery packs,
uh,
they often don't do that or they won't
charge from solar because they have a
really narrow voltage range on the input,
um,
and various other issues
that come with it.
And so that's kind of our job without
battery packs is to figure out how to get
them charging efficiently from solar
and do things like not only charge and
discharge at the same time,
but allow us to bypass the sleep
mode so it can just be on forever.
And you can,
you know,
leave it out in the mountains
running whatever sensor you've got.
And it'll still be there doing the same
thing in a year. And if it runs flat,
it'll bounce back when the sun
comes back and so on. So, um,
it depends on the scale of your project
as to what we could recommend. Uh,
our batteries are designed to do that,
but they're relatively small.
So our biggest batteries,
a 70 what our battery. Um,
after that we are getting into these
sort of now lithium ion batteries that
might be a couple of hundred watt hours.
Uh, we're starting to work on those,
but we don't have a
solution at the moment.
And I'm not sure whether
the other products out there
have actually solved that
problem.
Great. Let's, let's talk afterwards.
We'll show you one. Does the,
like the harvest inserted, the other
one's from at a fruit, but I'm using that.
Is that, can that be used to
solve this problem with this?
I think so.
Like it seems like it's almost daily
one capacitor away it seems like,
but you should look at the
fruit on silver harbor,
so they have the one that's on that helmet
because I feel like it's almost there
if he's got a big capacitor
where you're drawing,
it seems like it could
smooth it out for you.
Yeah, it might. That's a good question.
I have tested the added free one with
compatibility with our panels and
batteries and, and it works
relatively well. Uh, I,
I love all kind of ate fruit stuff,
but there's kind of two big problems
that he's facing and I don't,
I don't know if that solves it.
The first is does it constantly discharge
small power or turn back on when the
device wants power?
Turns it off. That's why. Exactly.
Exactly. Yeah. Most most USB
packs on the market we'll,
we'll turn off after repeat of time
of no load. So it needs to stay on.
And then the second part is if it
runs flat and then is recharged,
does it automatically turn the
USB port back on? Um, and uh,
that's something that we designed
into our batteries in the eight.
Everyone might do that as well.
Other questions?
No, this one doesn't charge
laptops. That one looks bigger.
It that actually managed to charge
laptops. It's the question is does that,
does the larger one charge a laptop?
Yeah. So the one on the top left is
designed to charge your laptop and your,
this is where the efficiency question
really becomes relevant because we've only
got so much space on the outside of a bag.
And as you can see,
we've used everything
available in that design. Uh,
and even then that a 10 watt panel and
really we could quite comfortably use 20
watts and charge at twice
the rate for a laptop.
But getting a laptop charger on a backpack
is, is a relatively difficult thing.
And so, um, yeah, that's,
that's been a challenge for us.
We've also got a like a briefcase thing
that's effective and then the foldout
panels can be quite good, but you've
got to stop and lay them out and so on
batteries bigger and you
need a higher output.
Voltage is obviously for
laptops as well as USB.
And then all of the same challenges with
restarting from flat and always on that
sort of thing.
Also,
the amount of power you need for a
Chromebook for a sense of backfoot pro are
very, very different. The find the laptop
very, very different. And so it's,
you know, I wouldn't recommend it for,
did I do that? I wouldn't recommend
it for a 15 inch Mac book.
It's just too small to, to produce
that amount of power. But, uh, it's,
it's nice to say tablets and more
efficient laptops out there that,
that we can feasibly charge from solar.
I think what, you know, one
of the interesting things is
when you think about the communities
that are off the grid, the, they,
they rapidly getting cell phones and
cell phones are still the old flip phones
and so on.
But pretty quickly they're becoming
the smart phones and tablets and energy
efficient laptops.
And you can really see a scenario where
the,
the off grid house of the future and in
developing countries is all DC based.
And starting with a solar light, maybe
a phone charge, you slowly expand those,
those systems so that you can then be
running all the stuff that used to run off
a whole bank of lead acid batteries and
multiple panels on the roof and so on.
So,
you know,
I think it's an exciting time for
solar and these devices really fit well
with, uh, with what's happening. What's
the primary chemistry and your batteries,
are they, are they, um, civil
that asset or they lipos
I batteries. Lithium polymer.
Yeah. Yeah. And they, you know,
so more energy dense then and,
and um, much lighter,
obviously the lead acid, uh,
the future I think is
lithium iron phosphate,
which doesn't have the same safety
concerns that you have with lithium ion
lithium polymer. Right, exactly. And you
know, that's certainly something that I,
I worry about it
really well.
Yes.
You want to pack more and more energy
into a smaller employer that's called
innocent.
Close that at some point. Yeah.
Yeah. And especially with the mine,
it's in a little tube that's
a pipe bomb. Um, but you know,
fortunately the, the incidents
is a relatively few, uh,
I would feel much more comfortable if
ultimately we can get to lithium iron
phosphate that doesn't explode.
Apparently we haven't got there yet,
but we're working on it. Yes. No, no,
not about batteries have responded, caught
fire or anything else. Thank you. Tony.
Ellen, how much is in your, or wearables?
So the question is how much is way
to factor in your consumer wearables?
As far as, I guess like what
makes it practical? Like how,
what's the maximum weight we can pack
in more a bigger battery where it,
right. At what point does
it come in? Practicum?
Yeah, that's, that's
definitely the trade off. Um,
we try and strike a balance with each
of the different products so that,
you know,
we've got a relatively small battery
and a small panel design as a cell phone
set up next level's tablets and laptops.
And we also try and can set it up so that
the customers can configure it as they
need to. If they want to upgrade to a
bigger battery that in mind could way Dan,
then we can do that. And
then of course, you know,
products like this one a much,
much lighter.
And so we're really, wait
is the primary concern, uh,
people might compromise a little on,
on functionality and go for something
like this that it's much easier to hike
with and so on.
So it's really up to the customer.
As a former laptop guy in the
park and cafe that I was, um,
one of the things I always
found actually was what the,
considering the weight of the laptop I
used to put up against the weight of the
charger, you know, the world
war and the battery life.
Like if I could get a laptop
the last than seven hours, I,
she just lost a pound because then
have to turn bad luck and likewise and
getting a bag if the bag,
wait another pound,
but I didn't need my wallboard
anymore. You know, that's,
that has to be considered as well.
Yeah, absolutely. And one of
the things we tried to do is,
because we also have ac charges
for the batteries as you know, if,
if you're not going to be
getting access to the grid,
we set up a bunch of little adapters so
you can just take one ac charger with
you and charge both our battery and the
laptop from the, from the same thing.
It's definitely an issue. The amount
of Chunky one I'm carrying around.
Yup.
What's new in the pipeline you share?
Well, the future, the future
full of Voltaic uh, yeah,
certainly this, this actually,
um, is, is the new product and a,
and we've got similar ones on the way.
Uh,
they're not in the market and we
haven't shown anyone else yet,
but this is a laptop. This is actually
more like seven each tablet, cell phone,
et Cetera, double that. And you're
getting to 10 watts and charging a laptop.
Uh, so there's that. But you know, the,
the stuff that really excites
me is both the iot applications.
And so that's us doing,
you know,
multiple small scale panels that are
sort of ready to go off the shelf and the
custom panels.
And you know,
it's really interesting for us when
people were coming to us with amazing
projects and asking us to
provide the power solution and a,
and we get to participate in that.
Uh,
and then for me personally in particular,
but for all of us,
the idea of having an impact
in developing countries and,
and providing electricity
where there's none is really,
you know, it's, it makes it all
worthwhile. And, uh, you know,
we'd been doing some truth. We just,
when we launched the solar light,
we did a buy one give one program
and our Kickstarter backers, uh,
enabled us to go down to Nicaragua and
visit a whole bunch of villages that had
no electricity and get up on the roof and
install lights and that sort of thing.
And so for, for us, that's
definitely a big part of the future.
That particular panel is
the same as are others. And,
and so what we're using at the moment is,
uh,
most recently world monocrystalline cells.
And you see, I can probably show
you the, the production process.
You know, we slice up the cells and
the reason you do it is to try and,
because the single saddle is half a volt,
so you slice it up into
multiple pieces like this.
You run them all in series and
a and solder them together.
And so you see here, this is sort of
our production process in summary, um,
what's happened and on the right weight
coding the panels in poly urethane and
it has a great life in the sunlight, 10
years plus. And so that's why our panels,
uh, sort of that shiny, uh, look, if you,
if you look at some of the
newer cells coming out,
there's the sunpower cell and these guys
are getting up to about 24% efficiency.
Uh, and so we're starting
increasingly to use these cells.
They're a little more complicated to work
with. Uh, and we need to laminate them.
We can't go into menopause early. So, um,
next steps for us in paddle development
will be at least to add these, uh,
to the mix and they'll look much more
like this folder where it sort of
disappears. You know, the
sale is almost invisible. Uh,
and this is a different
manufacturing process, laminated,
but much more power per square
inch. And, um, I, you know,
importantly for us,
better looking. So that's,
that's one element of our future
where, where is the demand
right now? Where are you,
where are you shipping your stuff too?
And what in what form?
Like what does your
popular product and target,
it's, it's sort of all over
the place. Um, and, uh,
we keep getting a little bit blindsided
by it because we've got sort of a steady
consumer products business
and we're selling online on
our website and elsewhere
and, and that sort of hums along. Uh,
but then particularly the
aid organizations will come
to us with virtually no
notice and say,
hey,
we want your entire stock of this product
that we've never ordered before and
all of a sudden were wiped out.
So, um, I'll put in a good way,
a good way.
Yeah.
So the aid organizations in particular
buying backpacks or similar products that
sort of strap onto a backpack,
um,
and then the,
the maker community or the,
the sort of industrial iot
applications at the same sort of thing,
they'll come to us and want large
quantities of a particular panel or the
Alaskas with,
you know,
I'll go through the whole process
to try and do it themselves.
And then at the very last minute come back
to us and say, Hey, we need, you know,
5,000 of these in three
weeks, can you do it? And, um,
we started scrambling to
try and try and deliver
what like was that a good problem?
Good problem to have? Yeah. Yeah.
Keeps it keeps tiny working hard.
Work hard.
Next questions.
No, all these ones. Okay. The question
is all these manufactured by him?
It's, it's a good question. And uh,
and that's actually changing too.
So you see in the,
in the middle photo up there,
that's how you know the, the laser
cutting on the left is automated,
the soldering of the cells is by hand.
And so it's this crazy
labor intensive process, ah,
and prone to all sorts of problems.
And then the coding of the panel
with polyurethane can be automated.
So there are robots that will sort of
dispense the right amount, but uh, it,
it forces this sort of
industry to be done in,
in places with lower labor costs.
And so you don't actually
see any manufacturer on a
small scale solar panels in
the U S and we've looked at doing
it ourselves. And really it just,
it just does not off at the moment.
But with these some power cells,
it's going to open up a really interesting
opportunity because instead of having
a positive and negative contact
on the back and the front,
as with the traditional sell,
all the contacts are on the back.
And what that means is
you can slice the cell up,
mounted on it and use an SMT
process to mount it on a PCB.
And Ron it through the oven,
all the electrical connections are made.
And so basically the whole thing can
be automated and you can get to a point
where the production costs for a
small scale panel at much, much lower.
And so we're working with different
factories that have that capability. Um,
ultimately I could see that being done
in the u s because it eliminates so much
of the labor cost. Um, but you
know, interestingly, it's, uh, I,
I guess the big challenge at the moment
is these plastic laminates don't have
the same life and the sun,
they're probably around
three to five years at best.
And so what we're doing is looking for
higher quality laminates that allow us to
produce that sort of a panel.
But with a 10 year life and a,
and we're very close to
being able to do that.
That's interesting.
Before I heard you mentioned 10 year and
that stuck in my head and I wanted to
bring this up so I bought some,
a lot of people have them. Sure.
Some really cheapo,
you know,
sharper image level solar lights and
a year later they were yellow. Yeah.
And I felt like, oh my God, like the cell
is still in there. It's just blinded.
Right.
Glad to hear you say that you're allowing
me to count because that's what a
thing to put it to fail on.
Well, it's crazy, right? I, you know,
when I first started looking at this,
I looked at every supplier I could find
and basically they are making chunk and,
and it's not that all solar is junk.
If you look at a rooftop module,
you can get a 25 year warranty on
that good quality in the same cells,
but somehow in the small
scale panel market, it's junk.
And I think what's happened is that there
you can go to home depot and buy six
to $36 and I think ours is,
consumers have in part just driven down
the price that we're prepared to pay.
And in parallel or maybe
first the manufacturer's
drove down the quality of what
they were making, if you think
right. And so if you think about who,
what do you use a small scale panel for?
It's 95% garden lights.
And so that's the quality
of what people were making.
And what you're talking about is an
epoxy laminated panel. The crazy,
you know, it's very similar to the
urethane applied in a similar way.
All the rest of it,
the crazy thing is not UV resistant and
so that they're specifically using a
material that doesn't hold up in
the sun to make small scale paddles.
Exactly, exactly. And no one seems
to care of it. Brilliant. Yeah.
So we've, you know, we pay five times
as much to use urethane and you know,
we're over engineering because it's
going to last longer than a backpack
possibly could.
Great.
Other questions?
Oh are they recyclable? The, the
components that are not junk to, uh,
to some extent the bags themselves,
the fabric is actually recycled pet.
So soda bottles. And so, you know,
we're definitely conscious of that.
We've used that or where we can,
but there's not a process whereby a PT
fabric can go back into recycling and uh,
and get reused.
It may be that it can get sort of down
cycle depending on where you live and
what their systems are.
And so on lithium polymer batteries,
we send our batteries off
to recycling centers. Uh,
I don't, I don't think it's a
particularly efficient process for those.
The silicon cells,
unfortunately we've, you know,
you're mixing together multiple different
types of material. The substrate,
the coating,
the cell itself.
And actually it's such a thin wafer
silicon that it's not a huge amount of
material there. So, um,
I'm not aware of any sort
of great recycling process
for particularly ourselves.
If you look at a rooftop module,
then you've got glass,
a glass panel and aluminum frame.
Both of those are sort of
well suited to recycling.
Thanks.
Definitely more for style projects.
That's the
solar panel.
I wanted a small weather as
I can find plenty of like,
but it seemed like all the small ones
I have to basically build some sort of
like
are there now like small enclosed
panels that I can just leave outside
for small, you know, whether is' panels.
Yeah. Surprisingly difficult
to find. Right. Sorry,
I was just, uh, but because this is
fully encapsulated with urethane,
um, this is an example of that.
Yes. Here it is. Yeah. Okay.
And then I'd live in Matt.
Most of them seem to be the small glass
panels with a big clunky aluminum frame
and you know,
they,
they made it the same way or rooftop
module is scaled down and so they work and
last as long, uh, but often
just too heavy, fragile,
whatever it might be. So that
could be left to the right. Yeah,
it can,
while you're facing is a very common
problem for outdoor sensors and outdoor
projects.
I talked to an engineer,
like an agricultural sensor
company and he's like, yeah,
we found some great small solar panels
and then they do laminated in the rain
after six months. Uh, so, um,
yeah, it is very difficult to,
to waterproof it,
but since it's fully encapsulated,
it's not only good in the rain.
We've had these bobbing on the Indian
Ocean for months and the full water salt
water, yeah. They, they are
saline resistant. Um, and
there was no de lamination.
Um,
so if yeah,
they're definitely capable and that's why
we say they're kind of over engineered
for the backpacks. Um,
but yeah, rain, snow,
water submersion there.
They're fully tight.
Cool.
How can we take one more question
or no more questions? Okay.
Going once, going twice.
Okay.
Would that,
thank you very much guys.
It's good to see this kind of stuff,
the good seed quality that there actually
is advances in this cause this is
what's going to save the planet.
Right?
Yeah. And I think the other thing to say
is that I'm sure you're working on some
really interesting projects and that's
the sort of stuff that gets us excited.
Anytime you want to talk to us, you
know, engineering at Valtech systems, uh,
or come out and visit us.
We're at the navy yard and the
new lab building up in Brooklyn.
I ride by every morning. Right,
right. And you know, really, uh,
it's this sort of stuff that's really
exciting for us to participate in the Iot
and the maker type application.
So let us know.
We'd be happy to help get involved,
do whatever we can.
Great. Actually 20, I'll talk to you about
my iot up solar powered burglar alarm.
Oh yeah, sorry. That's the
project that we're a building,
just moved up to electronic. Okay, great.
Thanks very much guys. And Michelle,
thank you.